take what's your best advice for young
men out there making 30 40 50 Grand a
year how can they get to 100 Grand how
can they get to the level where you're
at today what's your best advice the
most important piece of advice this is
only for people younger than 18 is oh my
God try in school I have never met an
intelligent person over the age of 18
that says oh I think I tried hard enough
at school dude always push a little more
whether you have to study a little bit
more or whatever there are so many
opportunities open to you before 18 that
trying harder in school will get you and
if you blow those up like if you you
know once you hit like 20 21 22 once
you've settled into like the working
Rhythm things get way way way way harder
in life so yeah study a little bit more
so your advice to younger people is like
do good in school yeah do seriously
seriously is not overrated it's
absolutely no okay what's your advice
for the 22 year old guy who just
graduated school 25 year old guy who's
just even a 30 year old guy who's not
killing her right now what's your advice
for that for rough Financial advice damn
um I would say that uh you said you
brought up something earlier people own
only look at the wealth accrual side of
like how much money you have the
spending side is really important yeah
um you know like if you want to lose
weight you start tracking your calories
if you want to save money you need to
make a budget if you're like a money
conscientious person and you're making
less than like 50k a year you should
absolutely have a budget once you start
budgeting things and you see how much
like that Starbucks every day adds up or
whatever type of like little
expenditures you do those things add up
so much throughout the year
um yeah I think that would be good to
keep track of so make a budget yeah I
think where your money goes what I call
a budget is having a game plan for your
money because budget is one of the
things I say is the only thing worse
than having a budget for your money is
not doing a budget for your money sure
so I call it having a game plan for
money there's two aspects to your game
plan there's income and there's expenses
people's focus on the income that's your
offense they don't realize that your
expenses is your defense and that's
leaks that it's kind of coming through
that so I fully Advocate that what's
your best advice program
um see my advice is a bit idealistic but
it worked for me and this is something
my dad always told me um he always just
told me to do what you're passionate
about because you're going to work
harder at it than everyone else because
you're passionate about it and you
actually like it so that's what worked
for me yeah I think what this is a
constant conversation that we know
should you follow the money or should
you follow your passion where wherever
those it for me follow the money because
once you make the money you can work on
your passion I.E I did worked in finance
for 15 years made money and now I'm
passionate about this [ __ ] I still do my
job but this is what I'm passionate
about the challenge is when you follow
your passion and let's say your passion
is
basketball or makeup or baseball cards
you might not be able to monetize that
and then you're 35 years old you're like
but I was following my passion but I do
agree what you should do is find out
what you are passionate about where you
can make money and where those two
intersect is where you can focus on I
just think with the internet like
because I'm thinking of another thing
I'm passionate about which is like
volleyball right and I'm just thinking
with the internet there's so many ways
you can combine the two so like if I was
going to do volleyball I'd probably do
you know something with volleyball
content or like teaching or you know
something like that it doesn't do us all
a favor do not quit your day job and
focus on volleyball I know I actually
it's funny I was offered a pro contract
in the fall and I was gonna go to either
Portugal or Germany but the YouTube
stuff was going so I had to make a
choice I choose but this is exactly what
I'm saying Pearl your passion is
volleyball you can make approximately 14
from volleyball you could make a million
dollars in a year doing YouTube might as
well work yeah but I was passionate
about both but yeah yeah you're right
you're right Hey listen I'm going to
take that I'm going to take that W right
there that's a win right I just always
told me he didn't care if we were
passionate about selling toothpicks on
the side of the road just do something
you love and yeah that's what my dad
would tell me I would say I would say
you have to find that balance because if
you're all about the money you're going
to get burnt out you have no idea how
many guys I know that went to Wall
Street started working at Wall Street
firms in their early 20s and by the time
they're [ __ ] 30 they had a million
dollars in the bank and they have like
no hair left they're like they're gonna
on suicide watch because their entire
life was just consumed with money and
like there's no balance with that but if
you're about but if you're only about
your passion and your broke as [ __ ]
that's also a bad situation to be in so
finally that happy medium I think you
have to find like jobs to empower your
hobbies I think is like the good thing
to do because not it depending like my
hobby was music yeah like I went to
school for music and everything but like
I had my job on the side because
realistically I don't know if I'm gonna
be a [ __ ] famous saxophone player
like making you know money to pay the
bills so um yeah that finding the
balance is really important because not
everybody can make it you're saying
having the balance with what like have
like if you have a passion that's good
but like you have to make sure you can
monetize it so I I I I have I have one
addendum to that I'm not going to try to
one-up you I'm just one addendum okay I
would say know your skill set and
utilize that to make money meaning mice
like it it's I'm not shocked that I'm
hosting a show
I was like always a funny kid in school
I was always loud I did stand-up comedy
for years I was a club promoter was a
nightlife guy I was always good with
networking socializing so I got into
sales and I was very comfortable as an
extrovert understanding that I am this
type of person and I was like all right
how can I make money with this type of
Personality well sales networking being
the business guy like that so there's
two pieces of ice here and then I want
to get your your advice Alex
so here's my advice and and this is for
the people at home are you an introvert
are you an extrovert which one are you
pick one pick one I'm an extrovert okay
you might be more of an introvert I
don't know you're an introvert Okay cool
so there's two things you could do if
you're an extrovert the way you can
monetize being an extrovert is get into
something with sales networking social
dynamics interacting with people
understand that if you're an introvert
there's something called the riches are
in the niches be [ __ ] great at
something very specific where you
whether it's a doctor an accountant a
tax guy whatever whatever it is engineer
and you can sit there in front of a
computer YouTuber and you understand
analytics and data and just [ __ ] be
the man now where you can be the goat is
where you can blend those two skills be
the best at one specific skill set but
also using your social like Equity right
there and combining those and that's
amazing so look at Pearl Pearl is a very
very good question asker very good I've
noticed about that so you're all you're
would you say that you're a very high
uh extrovert or not really
um I'm in the 97th percentile for
extroversion yeah okay so what you're
good at is if you you use your your
extrovert skills 97 somehow she knows
that but also I would say that you're
very high technical ability like you
understand YouTube or you just you
understand how to delegate YouTube okay
and you combine those so it's no secret
because I've seen you do your panel
you're asking questions of a wide range
of people but you understand how to
delegate the introvert skills right and
that's why I think you've had so much
success and the shorts yeah it's it's
really important to know what you're bad
at and Outsource it I would say like for
example I'm not I'm not great at
managing people like I just got too much
going on I can't manage all these people
you can barely manage your own schedule
Pearl I've had to help you [ __ ] clean
up your act of the last week
in a goddamn airport right now for one
for your voice I would not I found my
car I found my car she was like reliving
Dude Where's My Car okay oh my God we
found it okay yeah but but it's really
good to like be able to Outsource that
stuff so like I found a manager that
could help like manage people and like
because he's bad I'm not very good at
attention to detail so it was really
good for me to Outsource that because
that's just not a skill what I fully
agree with is recognize what you're good
at Double Down on that and what you're
not good at delegate okay you're very
good at understanding Dynamics and
dating right yeah how did you get to
that and how were you able to basically
start monetizing your skill set wait can
I uh first before I answer that sure
disagree with Destiny as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible